You may have heard the saying: "The early bird was like a worm before others," but for
Human, do the early have benefits on their old peers? Do you sleep early?
More intelligent or successful than others in this struggle over sleep time?
The surprising fact is that we do not have much to say about sleep preferences, as
It's like being genetically engineered. It is likely that if you are an evening,
Inherited from your ancestors who were also slow. From an evolutionary perspective,
It is understandable; acquisition of people at different sleeping times can group
To obtain full protection the length of the skill and the night. Instead of everyone sleeping
At the same time, some people by their very nature remain vigilant late, as others tend to wake up early in order to be aware of the risks
Or predators while others sleep.
However, as most of the activities of modern societies occur between 9 am and 5 pm, it is clear
That the Messians are in a loss. Researchers put the term
"Social disorder" to explain sleep deprivation to take into account
milieu. For the evacuees, this disorder is felt by them
They live in a different time zone every day. Sleep deprivation affects the role of the brain
It is not surprising that studies prove that students are college students
Their scores are lower than their peers. Early people also have positive social characteristics
Such as positive and proactive, and are less likely to be depressed or addicted
Nicotine, alcohol and food.
We can see these properties physically on the brain - especially white matter
Which help connect neurons. The subjects have less white matter
This results in lower neurotransmitter pathways to the happiness hormones such as sertonin and dopamine
To navigate.
Not all things are bad for the losers. In fact, they tend to be more innovative than others,
They have high mental abilities, and are known as psychics.
What detracts from the white matter, they make up for cortisol. Humon tension this
The body can face risks, which helps to take risks, which studies see
That it could turn into opportunities for financial gain.
In addition, although the morning is active after awakening,
Quickly, they do not make it difficult for Uo to turn against their poor peers. Both parties are doing the same
Effectiveness in speed tests after waking up an hour, but after 10 hours,
The evenings perform much better.
Your inner watch is regulated by many proteins that are made up of genes in your DNA.
Studies have shown that any slight change in nuclear conductivity, prior to the so-called gene
In the first cycle, it may change the time you wake up by an hour.
Surprisingly, scientists have found that there is a correlation between these genes and the time of your death.
Early people are more likely to die around 11am,
The evenings are before 6 pm.
What about teenagers? It is true that most of them are absent because of
Hormonal changes during puberty, but all this change fades over time to suit your genes
Until you reach puberty.
When there is some health of the saying that the early bird withers the worm, the night owls are not
Late in life, they are only late in time!
Do not forget to watch ASAPthought where you can participate
Test pop music
Click on the screen to share
Or link below
And share more science every week !.